for a change do you want to start in a
in a certain texas
metropolis i mean we never really do
well we haven't done that i'm glad you
mentioned that
i'm glad you mentioned that mike because
when i heard this news yesterday
i felt like a bad
local columnist local commentator
because a trade was made in my market
houston
and i didn't know about it we talk about
houston all the time for those who don't
know we always
we keep coming back to houston and james
harden and russell westbrook
fascinating and here we are again
russell westbrook going from houston to
d.c
john wall going from d.c to houston
not just john wall going there but a
first round pick a protected first round
pick i get it
that's big but a first round pick going
there
and the only thing mike i don't
understand here well i don't understand
a couple things here
but just uh maybe i can help you the
little side piece a little side piece
here is that
washington dealt as if it didn't have
leverage
like don't you know james harden james
harden didn't want russell westbrook
there anymore
they were going to move one of those
guys they were
pretty much locked up contractually they
don't have any draft picks
so you don't have to do what you don't
want to do unless
unless the wizards
thought that something else was
happening that we that we're not aware
of i'm not sure what it is
they didn't have to give up a first
round pick to get russell westbrook as
my point
i'm interested to say that because
both of us are westbrook fans yes
just happens to recognize his flaws a
little bit better than the other one
yeah but i thought that would be a
no-brainer from your perspective at
least because the best player in the
trade
is russell westbrook not just the best
westbrook but the healthiest player
so i get the first round sweetener
if you're washington and you want to
move on
from your former number one overall pick
in your former face of the franchise
who while younger uh is not as good a
better shooter which isn't saying much
but not as good um and you move on from
him
and bringing a guy who your head coach
is quite familiar with
i mean i think if you're the wizards you
upgraded so that first round pick
is a price worth paying if you're
houston
and this is where i start that's one way
i'm going to start but i would
just dovetail off of that yeah i got to
give a shout out to rafael rolling stone
i'm a new general manager daryl moore's
replacement
well i i thought they were stuck like
chuck you know that
you know especially when the trade
rumors and the reports of
uh you know unrest within that
organization
and your two superstars both wanted out
for different reasons
all that stuff started happening i'm
like look you're not gonna get better
around these two
maybe you can get different so to speak
but you're not gonna get better
so might as well blow it up you know
everybody's playing for second
in the nba right now to the lakers
anyway this isn't a championship roster
don't get mired in mediocrity any more
than you already are you know
trade them both i said because there's
not much you could do you kind of you
know
the the cupboard's bare when it comes to
assets as you mentioned earlier but
raphael stone is fooled around and when
he went and stole christian wood from
the pistons
okay see that's a good that's what we
love we both love that first date
robert covington to portland for ariza
the 16th pick
and a 2021 protected picket from not
mistaken they flipped
ariza and the 16th pick to
detroit for christian wood love that
pickup for them right so they get him
getting rid of westbrook for a wall
there's some upside there okay to get
wall back
because whoa maybe he gels better
than russell westbrook did who knows but
because wall washing
joe's better with harden with hard and
i'm sorry yes that then okay
then russell westbrook did and look let
me john wallace
let me remind me to come back to that
okay no problem i'll be quick
but john wall that's some upside there
if he if he's actually as good as he's
reportedly looked in workouts coming off
the achilles
then it's not like they they got a scrub
back for russell westbrook they got a
pretty damn good player
a fellow five-time all-star great note
by the way
two times in nba history have players
who each have five all-star appearances
minimum five all-star appearances been
traded for each other
chris paul russell westbrook russell
westbrook john wall so
this is somewhat unprecedented what
we're seeing here we'll get to the
ripple effects in a second
but point being is if you're using you
get back john wall
so you remain competitive and i'll get
to this in a second too you remain
attractive
to uh your current partner as in james
harden
and you get this protected first round
pick back so now you've gotten back two
picks this offseason if i'm tracking
this right
one from um from portland
and one from uh now the wizards
so you're kind of restocking the
cupboard if you will listen i don't know
what demarcus cousins has left
but that's a high up that's a low low
risk high reward move to bring in
demarcus cousins
let's just leave i like that stone let's
leave but i gotta say boogie out of this
they're okay but my point is hey look
maybe it makes john wall happy i don't
know
point being is they're tinkering and i
like what rafael stone has done
he's done a lot with a little it looked
like how are they going to get out of
this mess
and he's reshaped the team i just got
off the radio with rich eisen a second
ago
and he was like this is just shuffling
furniture on the deck is all this is i'm
like yeah but sometimes your apartment
or your house can look totally different
just by moving furniture around i don't
know about you but yeah my mom all the
time she loved to move furniture
and i come in i'd be like damn did we
move this is like a different house so
far
they're pretty good so it could it but
you know what but you know what happens
in that case
i love that analogy but let's just stick
with that analogy just for a second
when you move things around in your
house and initially you say
man i never really appreciated this
window or this table
in this alignment and then after a while
you get used to it and say it's at the
same old place
so i don't believe i don't believe that
we're in that situation because like you
actually said off the top
i think russell westbrook is such a
dynamic underappreciated player
my only question here for washington yes
he is the best player
in the trade and i say wait until uh
when the east
meets west westbrook because he's never
been in the eastern conference
and he has done some damage out west
which has
historically been the stronger
conference and he has done
his best work there when he gets to the
east
i think his numbers will stay the same
if not rise
my question is they got a fun looking
lineup i like the lineup is pretty fun i
do
they will
i think the best best situation for
russell westbrook
and go back a little bit here just so
you can see
the the comparison when allen iverson
played for philly they're always like
that second scorer
you know larry hughes for a while jerry
stackhouse worldwide all these second
scores they didn't quite fit
with alan iverson and eventually larry
brown said all right best way
to feature allen iverson let him do his
thing it's just let me just
liquidate the roster of scorers you know
yeah so he's playing with like george
lynch and
eric snow and uh time maintenance that
would be tyrone hill that was his
nickname type name this great nickname
but all these guys in dikembe so
a lot of guys who didn't demand the ball
and that's when alan iverson really
started to flourish in philadelphia went
to the nba finals
i really believe that russell westbrook
is at his best
when he can just dominate the ball some
people call it ball hog i'm not so
judgmental
i say let russ cook and that's how russ
cooks
hey that's marked hey be careful that's
trademarked a guy in seattle i think he
trademarked that
shout out russell wilson shout out i
like you like you on ig too do some good
stuff
um but can russell westbrook really
reach his his his mark his his uh his
best place
with bradley beal because bradley beal
is a bad boy
he got himself last year and would he
like it well he liked it
well uh don't lose your thought we'll go
back to houston in a second
about the fit with walden harden but you
know westbrook's got some shooters
around him
okay uh that's why no i'm not i'm
staying in washington that's what i'm
talking about
but but you had a thought no you had a
thought earlier that you never got to
about the whole heart of fitness oh
don't don't worry you up
don't worry but i want to jump in on the
washington part of this
um because he's surrounded by some
shooters you know i mean they got
a pretty uh interesting lineup um
uh i like what they did in the draft as
well
and so i think that's your point if
that's my point no it's my boy
they drafted right uh yeah well ibia
abdial abdia thank you
yes uh i remember the wine cellar i
remember the wine cellar when they
announced his name on draft night uh so
he's a man of good taste
um but i think if he he can dominate the
ball
and the offense can run through him but
he does need to find his shooters
because listen i'm not trying to hem i
don't want to beat a dead horse
but i just you know you tend to not
listen to me
when i say things sometimes other people
have to say it for it
for the register i know our relationship
so
my man kirk goldsberry analytics savant
pointed out that out of 50 players
who have taken at least 2500 jumpers
over the last five seasons
russell westbrook is dead last
in efficiency with an effective field
goal percentage
of 42.5 on 4814
jumpers so you know you know what my
question that's just
that's just an illustration of the fact
that let russ cook
but only certain dishes within a certain
proximity of the basket if you follow
what i'm saying
all right you know what my question is
for kurt goldsberry with his chart
and his tweet what'd that do
hi what do you mean hey okay i mean i
just
in case you just in case the words
coming out of my mouth
so i mean we are scott brooks
get russell westbrook to find these
shooters uh
you know they [ __ ] paid so funny
though they played they paid burton's
help on pronouncing his last name right
they paid him a bunch of money
a great shooter we talked about him the
other day the money they gave him
so they got they got people they could
spread the floor let him attack let him
be explosive
but get rid of it and let other people
shoot i'm not gonna go too far off the
point
i'm not gonna go too far off the point
let me just make this
clear for some of the
uh some of my fellow mathletes
you analytics people like me
nerds no game whatsoever no game
and so in analytics i got no game and i
love it too i do love analytics
but sometimes you got to say hold on now
analytics says that
cam newton and tom brady are having
comparable seasons just for example for
example advanced stats say that
and for russell westbrook do they for
him to be d wait like that wasn't
definitely that was advanced
advanced tests yes look it up advanced
stats say
russell uh that tom brady and cam newton
are having comparable seasons
and cam newton has thrown for four
touchdown passes and tom brady is 28 but
anyway
anyway um so why
no let me say that let me say another
way how come
russell westbrook russell westbrook
can't shoot
he's averaged a triple-double three
times in his career
john wall is a better shooter supposedly
he's shooting
43 percent he's shooting 43 for his
career
he's last time he played a full season
he shot 32 percent from three-point
range
45 from two-point range so i'm not
saying he's i'm not saying he's a
marksman
i'm not saying he's a marksman remember
i qualified it earlier i said
he is a better shooter which isn't
saying much hence the graphic
i'm not sure i'm not here to degrade
russell westbrook i'm agreeing with you
that he has a type he got he got it
russell westbrook got what he wanted
bradley bill's the man in washington
don't get me wrong but this has an
opportunity to be russell he has the
opportunity to be the floor general
it could be his team again which he had
to defer a lot of that to james harden
obviously
he has the shooters around him to make
the wizards an interesting team in the
east
we're agreeing we're just agreeing
differently going back to houston though
maybe wall might be more comfortable
in that role that secondary role to
james harden
we'll see we'll see how they know they
both got a lot to prove
what's fascinating is that harden
apparently according to woage
preferred wall over westbrook okay
if that's true yeah interesting because
i mean
respectfully james harden got
relationship issues because he
clearly seems hell-bent on playing with
every star in the nba before it's all
said and done
so it's like what's this we've been
through dwight i mean he's running
through him
i mean you know i like i like hardened a
lot and i say this affectionately i
really do say this affectionately
but james harden is a nba thought as the
kids would say like he didn't ran
through him
i mean he didn't ran dwight howard he
didn't ran through cp3
he didn't ran through uh russell
westbrook carmelo anthony had a cup of
coffee
i mean now it's on the john wall he may
end up back with kevin durant and kyrie
irving in brooklyn i mean he gets around
to say the least that's what but you
remember that houston
that's where he's like to his desire
yeah go ahead
exactly that's exactly that's the point
i wanted to get back to
and remember a few weeks ago i had on
the feed i said every james
is in a team builder uh comparing you
know james harden to lebron james for
example
where you just kind of know of this guy
we would play well together i think
james harden
either he thinks he's a team builder or
the general managers
that have been in houston believe
what he says about team building and
they just kind of bring in anybody
so i i don't know if if russell
westbrook is the problem
or if chris paul was the problem or
dwight howard or
maybe it's just james harden by the way
can i just say
this about my man russell westbrook
he's continuing to get a bad rap he
never
asked for any of this he never asked for
any of this why was he trading
he never asked to be traded in the first
place from oklahoma city why was he
trading from oklahoma city
because paul george we'll talk about him
later paul george
left he didn't asked he may not have
asked
or he made or he may not have had
necessarily the leverage but when you
got a max deal you got a massive
contract like russell westbrook
oh yeah there's going to be some
conversations either with sam yeah
but that's what it was like he wanted to
go to houston he may not have liked what
he found when he got there
but he wanted to go to houston don't get
let's not get it he never asked
but he never asked out of oklahoma city
and said i got to get out of here no but
who gives him a bad way who gives him a
bad rap i think his loyalty is
unquestioned given that you know again
he stayed certainly contrary to and i'm
not criticizing him but contrary to
kevin durant did people appreciate him
in oklahoma city
and people also appreciate if you were
paying attention that he was playing
analytics great
basketball analytics played basketball
kirk goldsberry ain't loving them no but
just that's just facts more than one
thing can be true he was playing great
basketball
before the bubble then when he got to
the bubble covid in a quad
and he rushed back from that and didn't
play great against the lakers i think
people recognize that so nobody's
putting up giving a bad rap on russell
westbrook but she's going to take this
you're going to take offense to this
we only been talking about one end of
the floor i think wall in my opinion is
a better defender than russell westbrook
so if you're houston you get that and
but my main thing is houston
is still trying to appease
uh james harden even though reportedly
and
not just reportedly gave the cap no cap
demonstration on his
ig stories reportedly he may want out
but they're saying no we're going to run
this
back with you maybe we'll run it back
differently but we're keeping you around
we're not going to be bullied
or pushed into a trade that doesn't meet
our demands
so if they're still taking his opinion
about who he wants to play with i wonder
if that suggests
that they're just doing whatever it
takes to make him happy
or are there rumors and the reports of
his desire to leave houston
overstated and he's still working in
concert with them
either way going back to what i was
saying i like just i like how raphael
stone
rolling stone rafael rona stone has
played this houston off season
because it was a big hanging over him
and he's done a good job of trying to
turn the frown upside down
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 pm eastern time on peacock
appreciate you